[Music]
around the world from Los Angeles to
South
Korea filmmakers have tapped into organ
trafficking as a uniquely horrific
subject far at kidne Mom's heart it's a
horror that unbelievably exists in the
real world and to players in this game
your body is a collection of products to
be stolen or bought on the cheap and
then resold to buyers for astronomical
prices how much would you pay to save
your life both men paid over
$200,000 in order to obtain kidneys it's
a sizable amount of money this red trade
isn't a Hollywood cre a it's a reality
with origins in modern-day Africa Asia
and the Middle East in this Village
alone more than half the people living
here have sold one of their kidneys but
now rumors of the red trade are bubbling
up far closer to
home and I set my sights on finding the
people and organizations that are making
a killing in body
[Applause]
parts
so this is the liquid that's coming from
inside you yeah it's been in my stomach
cavity for about four or 5 hours right
now Garrett row is hoping to beat the
odds just kind of taking out the toxins
processing um what my kidneys aren't
doing to stay alive Garrett normally
spends 9 hours each night hooked up to a
dialysis machine I had a flu at one
point and they just noticed that my uh
blood pressure was a little high did
some blood work and then probably by
about 5:30 after I got home I got a
phone call and she said I have a room
for you at the emergency room you need
to go right now and so what was
happening um that they just were
shutting down your kidneys yeah soz as
of now I essentially have less than 3%
functionality wow I mean last year alone
I was almost a month and a half 2 months
in the hospital I was passing out I was
going head first into walls like I was I
just couldn't function so you're going
to me
I'll need one um to start and that
should hopefully I I hope it gets me at
best 20 more years and I'll probably
need a second one at that point and
you've been on on the list here in
Georgia for how long now oh jeez almost
2 years year and a half at least really
yeah on average they say it's like 7
years that you wait on the list on
dialysis it can roughly get you about 7
years extra before like you have to get
an Oregan so what happens if you don't
get an organ
then that's
it the numbers are brutal in the United
States 17 people die every day waiting
for an organ in 2020 over 39,000
Americans did receive a transplant but
over a 100,000 languished on a waiting
list hoping for a phone call that never
came we've already have very loose
conversations of what do we do when when
we when we don't get one I can't help
but wonder what I would do in a
situation where my life or the life of a
loved one was hanging in the balance and
a solution perhaps was for sale in the
underground what's Plan B where do we go
who do we know in other countries that
could help us out and set us up with
whatever we
need facing the same struggle how many
patients in America have made the
decision to take action to head towards
a destination where the will to live
overpowers Judgment of right and
wrong the mortality rate while waiting
for an organ in this country can
actually be more than 50% because we
don't have enough
organs in San Francisco Peter chin H is
an infection disease doctor who
specializes in transplant patients how
prevalent would you say are Black Market
organs in the United States so we know
the the floor which is at least 10% but
it's certainly much higher because the
10% is what we know about when you think
that you found a patient that has
performed the surgery elsewhere and has
a black market organ do you ask them so
it's a really difficult con conversation
it's Hush Hush what is it that you think
makes them not want to tell you the
truth embarrassment guilt um because
they didn't line up like everyone else
here uh and depending on how they got it
they could be fair of you know uh harm
maybe if you reveal identities of
certain organizations that might be
doing this and do you have any sense of
where these organs are coming from we
know that the Philippines China uh India
and some places in Eastern Europe but
there are undoubtedly other places as
well
no recipients under Dr Chin Hong's care
would agree to meet but combing through
social media there are ample clues of a
thriving trade overseas this one sells
kidney for $6,000 location is Rwanda 26
years old and healthy I mean it's just
message after message it's mostly
actually from developing countries you
know which is the really sad truth about
this and that makes me wonder with a
full-blown migrant crisis taking place
at our own borders could organ
trafficking be right here at the
doorstep of the United
States it's a question I put to my
context so any luck with this uh organ
trafficking story not really you know
I've been calling a whole bunch of
people they don't have anything
yet
experts say that organ trafficking is
widespread but incredibly difficult to
report often because the victims are
poor are willing participants and
there's no political will to go after
medical tourists and Wealthy doctors who
enable the
[Applause]
trade hey Oliver how are you doing fine
money on it yeah I've been in touch with
a couple of guys at organized crime they
basically are confirming that they are
more and more involved in illegal organ
uh trafficking oh wow so did you think
that if we go down to Colombia we'll be
able to film meet people and talk to
people about this
trade definitely definitely you should
come down
[Music]
here it's been almost 30 years since
Pablo Escobar was gunned down on a
rooftop in
medin but this region of Columbia has
remained AC Crossroads for cartel
activity and cocaine trafficking and if
my local producer Oliver schmig is
correct it's also becoming a hub for
organ
[Music]
traffickers normally when I set out to
report on a story whether it's drugs or
guns or scams I have some expectations
of how the market operates but here
there's no telling because this Market
if it exists is so
new there are no official reports no
arrests and no bodies if we are to prove
the existence of organ trafficking in
Colombia it will be an investigation
that begins with accounts from the
underworld to be viable an organ like a
kidney must come from a live donor or a
body that has just died and must be
transplanted within 36 hours preferably
even sooner if all of our sources are
correct and organs are being smuggled
out of Columbia that's a remarkably
short window for them to cross borders
and be transplanted into another body so
I've come to see if I can confirm it
with my own
eyes the town we're heading to turbo is
rumored to be the epicenter of smuggling
for Columbia's most dangerous cartel the
clan Del
goo and how dangerous is it to report in
this
region it's pretty dangerous I mean it's
a region which is controlled by the
biggest drug cartel in Colombia I would
easily say 80% of the population here is
connected to drug trafficking activities
Yes you heard that right and if you look
around cartel markings are
everywhere I've been to Turbo once
before to report on the movement of
cocaine but this time I'm looking into
something far more Sinister and in many
ways hoping it doesn't exist so we're
heading now to meet the commandante
which we met last time who was
trafficking cocaine right in charge of
this area yeah our first stop is to meet
with an operative known as the commander
who controls smuggling routs for the
clan granting safe path Mage to those
who pay the cartel and punishment for
those who don't this is
[Music]
him
for looking at a map it's easy to see
why the cartel has placed the commander
here and why it's one of the world's hot
spots for smuggling there are no Roads
connecting Colombia and Panama anybody
headed north must travel by boat or Pass
Overland through the Darion Gap a 100m
journey through one of the most
treacherous jungles in the
world controlling the Daran Gap is
crucial for the cartel which collects a
so-called tax on drugs and migrants and
now I'm being told on human
organs
[Music]
for
while we wait to see if the interv will
happen I'm headed 30 m North to the town
of niol
CLE if migrants are being targeted for
their organs in Colombia this is
probably where it would be
happening think we should go that way
maybe so this is the point the beach
where we hear a lot of the migrants
congregate before they make their way
across the sea this small town has been
been transformed from a minor tourist
destination to a choke point for
migrants who get stuck here for weeks at
a time waiting for a seat on a boat to
continue their Journey North to America
and you see there's the red crosses
[Music]
here migration and Refugee crisis have
been breeding grounds for Oregon
traffickers in other parts of the world
it's an economy of desperation just as
Garrett's desperation in America could
someday lead him to buy an organ on the
black market here in Colombia it's easy
to see how desperation could also fuel
someone's desire to sell
one
[Music]
heartbreak and hope are everywhere
here but evidence of organ harvesting is
elusive everyone here in his group has
heard rumors of organ trafficking but
he's not sure neither the Red Cross nor
the local police have confirmed anything
beyond scant
rumors but one policeman did agree to
speak with us on condition of
anonymity
for
foreign
[Music]
for
as these families prepare for the Perils
of the Darian Gap they're largely
upbeat the violence they're escaping in
their home countries feels far more real
than these rumors of organ
harvesting I on the other hand am
growing increasingly
concerned we've just been given the
location to go meet this uh man who
apparently goes by the name of this it's
an ominous name in Spanish this is the
word for somebody who tears apart cars a
record we don't know much about this guy
we've been told he's pretty high up on
the
Chain there's no light it's completely
dark and there's a
gate
H
Marana
foree
fore
for see I know
the go fast boats that he refers to
could certainly make it to Panama in
time for a kidney transplant but could
an organ be safely smuggled from here
all the way up to an operating room in
the United States and within just 2 days
I have my DS
[Music]
fore
for
Fore
fore
[Music]
the video he shows me is too gruesome to
show on television organs are being
removed from a dead body it's happening
in a surgical setting but there's no
care involved rather hands are pulling
organs from an open chest and casually
slapping them down on a metal
table whether they represent what he
claims I cannot say but by the time he's
walked away I feel like I can hardly
breathe that
[Music]
was heavy and horrible and Incredibly
dark and and
depressing and uh really difficult at
the same time to
I believe a lot of what he was saying
because it just sounds so
horrible I think the hardest interview
I've ever had to do in my life I mean
how much is he trying to make himself be
more important in this than he actually
is like he knows what he's doing that
I'm not sure and I don't think we ever
will
know egole plays an important role in
Black markets it's very often the reason
why people agree to talk to me and
sometimes it's difficult to parse the
truth from Bluster and
lies what I do know is that a business
that works for one criminal group is
often copied by
another and since the record has
mentioned ties to the Mexican cartels
I'm going to follow the story north even
closer to the US
[Music]
border
okay in other parts of the world organ
trafficking rooms have employed a small
army of accomplices recruiters doctors
nurses Hospital administrators even
people to launder the cash I'm hoping
that if I can find a low-level
accomplice doors might open to bigger
players
my search starts here with a Criminal
group that have been told buys kidneys
from Mexican citizens which are then
resold for transplant there's two guys
waiting inside the
car they're looking very suspiciously at
us
yes we're here it's a old house with
lots of trash
everywhere they're closing the gate
behind
us not the ideal
situation
[Music]
H hello hi so I hear you speak English
yeah how should I call you
him he's got a gun oh have to be
protected we this business so okay so I
had what do you do well I'm like a scout
I'm looking for the people who are
willing to willing to
donate and so how do you figure out if
these are people are even compatible we
have to make some um exams so if they
are let's go if they not sorry man we
took him here like a week where where is
here here here right here you serious so
this is actually where you bring the the
to rest to stay with us the vitamins and
how often do these organs end up in
American bodies W there's more lines
from American Site than from
Mexico so I hope you don't mind me
asking but we're in Mexico and we know
that nothing happens here without the
knowledge of the cartel
so
unlike the murder for organ scenario in
Colombia anhel says he's buying organs
not stealing
them but in both instances there's
undoubtedly the presence of organized
[Music]
crime and I've come here to make contact
with one
[Music]
group it's here
foreign foreign
fore
[Music]
Paloma describes a medical practice in
this town where surgeons work hand inand
with organized crime profiting from
transplants to wealthy Mexicans and
Americans
[Music]
the guy in prison um he's apparently
agreed to talk to us apparently he also
has a phone in prison and uh he said
that only after we speak to him will he
decide whether he lets us interview the
doctor or
not
[Music]
I've met up again with Paloma who's
letting me use her phone to speak with
her son-in-law in
prison
okay you speak English oh yeah you speak
English yeah this is a first for me I
spoken with crime bosses Behind Bars
before but none who've handed me off to
their assistant can you tell me how you
and and your boss how are you guys
involved in the organ trade what's
what's what exactly is your role in it
you know people come from another
countries and they pay a lot of money
that they need like lers they need kid
or stuff like that the demand for Black
Market organs according to is met with a
steady supply Supply provided by
patients at a local medical
clinic do they help us to see if they
are some people we just
[Music]
have you know it's a lot of money so
you're saying that sometimes that these
people they're not just selling the
organs because they want to you're
saying that you guys actually force them
to is that what you're saying yes yeah
and who are who are these people and
where do you find them work
with you know
because trouble for us how so what what
do you mean like how is it trouble
because how do they know anything I mean
if
I had thought that here in Mexico this
trade was about Commerce not murder but
it seems I was
mistaken
[Music]
okay so when that
happens
from do you think I could talk to the
boss again real quick I I wanted to ask
him a couple more
questions
[Music]
for okay
okay okay I mean
[Music]
for the boss never gave me a clear
answer about whether they were killing
people but it's not hard to read between
the
lines I'm pass the point of wondering
whether this trafficking Network exists
what I want to know now is how it
actually works and I'm hoping one of the
doctors at this Clinic can provide the
answers we've been in Columbia we've
been to Mexico several times now just
waiting for for this interview 3 days
pass by before the Call Comes so we've
been waiting for um over 2 hours now
they were supposed to get here at 2:00
it's now 4:10 this is actually the the
sixth doctor that we've contacted the
other five backed
out
hey okay coming
down isn't it
better so I'm going to put a microphone
on you
Doctor you know I was actually very very
nervous that you weren't going to come
so um can you tell me um what is it that
you do you're you're a doctor and in the
world of the black market what is it
that you do
exactly where
they
[Music]
for
for something feels off it seems this
doctor is only willing to go so far with
cameras
rolling I
[Music]
no see they were forced to to give
for
doctor describes his role as testing
Black Market donors and recipients for
compatibility before handing the results
to transplant
surgeons
[Music]
okay are you in touch with
them
but they gave you the okay to speak to
us
today we trust doctors to protect and
preserve life but here some combination
of coercion and a promise of profit is
turning into
murderers if I had doubts that the red
trade existed in Colombia I have none
that it's thriving here in
Mexico there is one stun left unturned
who are the
bias I've spent months looking for an
organ recipient willing to speak to
me finally from prison
pal
son-in-law has made an introduction I
did because I want to enjoy my
life I decided to talk to you because I
probably I'm going to be the only one
that you're going to find yeah we've
been trying for many months you're the
first one to agree to talk to us I did
what I did
to
survive in this world there's so many
ways to get what you want if you have
the move this is a man we'll call Juan 9
months ago he claims that diabetes
nearly took his life but he was saved by
a pancreas transplant obtained through
the same cartel connection how how do
you find an organ in a black market or
how do you even find the black market a
guy with the diabetes you give me a
little bit tiny information then I found
the rest of the information so you you
started asking around and then how soon
after were you able to actually get the
surgery I mailed my blo work mhm to a
certain place mhm and they thought that
I was ready how many people were in the
team is it a St I don't know I don't
know I'm not telling
you it's better not telling you you for
you for me because for whatever there
could be consequences to you telling me
for you and for me and how much did you
pay for the surgery
everything more than $100,000 more than
$100,000 more than $200,000 more than
$200,000 was it half a million
dollar a little bit
more a little bit more than half a
million
dollars and you have
200,000 and I have
300,000 I care I get it you
don't so you were ready to pay more than
anyone else I was ready to fight for my
life I just wanted to be away from the
dog the
pain I just needed to stop
suffering do you know where your
pancreas um came from of course not I
don't care I don't know nothing I don't
want to know nothing I just have the
money and I did it if it's a full
pancreas then the person that donated
the pancreas had to be dead but if it's
part of a pancreas it could have been
given by a person who's still alive
would it make a difference if you knew
would you would you have done anything
differently if you found out that they
had forced somebody or even possibly
killed somebody I would I I would have
uh no not do it you you would have not
done it I didn't done that you know no
no no it's not
nice so it was just good not to ask
questions this is nothing that I wanted
to go through this is not the life that
I wanted it for
me may I ask you a
question
ma'am if if you were my position if you
were me and that's the only choice you
got would you do
it I have no idea because I you'd have
to be in that position you were ready
for the question but I I have thought
about this many times and I I you know
if I think people go to Great Lengths to
to survive and to be able to continue
living and it's true ethical arguments
hit a wall when it comes to our own
Survival and and that of our families
what wouldn't I do what wouldn't any of
us do if our own life or our child's
life hung in the balance so you've never
felt inclined to go online and try to
see where you could possibly get a black
market
no I mean it's in like the back of your
head of like you know would you and you
know if someone said like hey I got an
Oregon like tomorrow okay let's figure
this out do this but like where where
can you turn who do you ask who do you
find out who do you trust right it's
hard enough to find like a weed dealer
like let on an
[Music]
Aran for somebody like Garrett who's
playing by the rules who deserves a
chance to live our society has an
obligation to make a more efficient
legal market so there's simply no reason
for a black market to
exist if we're a way to do it the right
way I would do
it it is
[Music]
not